I would I think there is no harm in
talks there is plenty of evidence
historically that that you may get much
more from talks than than not talking
and if not talking also means you have
two options you either let Iran go
nuclear or you have to get into a war
with Iran which can open the gates of
Hell in the Middle East essentially now
if those are your only options i think
talk the talking should be given its
chance even if that chance is very
little i think direct talking with Iran
can change the context of every issue
that's on the table you have to let the
Iranians decide whoo-hoo the
interlocutor is but the reality is that
it's not a good idea for the United
States to try to choose factions in Iran
that he wants to talk to this is bad and
ideas foreign governments trying to
decide they only want to talk to
Democrats we only want to talk to
Republicans and I think in the past I
think during the Clinton administration
one reason things didn't move forward
was because Washington basically made it
clear it only wants to talk to reformist
so you talk to the Iranian state and I
delay in ish alee the talks do not need
to be at the highest levels I mean you
just having serious talks by people who
are representatives of the states is all
that matters I think the personality of
talks are not as important right now as
a decision in America by President Bush
and in Iran by the Supreme Leader not by
the Iranian president because the head
of state and around the Supreme Leader
the decision by these two men the
supreme leader than the president united
states that they want a different
us-iran relationship and they want
constructive talks that's all that is
required for talks who actually sits at
the table is much less important than
getting that level of commitment that's
what happened with China I mean the
opening came when two men Mao and Nixon
decided they didn't know where they're
heading they didn't know who was going
to say what and what the talks would be
but they made the fundamental decision
that they're going to give a engagement
is serious chance